hey what is going on YouTube now even
without me saying it you guys know
police brutality has been a relatively
hot topic I just haven't touched on it
yet it's kind of been the thing that
media has been pushing down our throat
so it's a little bit hard to look over
and just as a disclaimer I don't hate
cops many times I really do need them
they're like ghetto kryptonite hey David
some bad yo cause smoke up what you do
for living I'm a cop
here's the thing going up with the type
of people that I did all of them hated
Popo saying [ __ ] like [ __ ] the police
Fargo always keeping a real cheat down
man don't you guys got like terrorists
to take down and central pressing my
people and it always alluded to them
saying that they weren't doing [ __ ]
because the cops was just bullying the
[ __ ] out of them but knowing my friends
are a piece of [ __ ] they weren't being
profiled they were just mad that they
got caught I can't even make this [ __ ]
up I kid you not one time I even caught
one of my Asian homies telling the cop
all right Vic it's cuz I'm black isn't
it now are you for real what is it
get you ass up here just catch a break
at that moment I was thinking to myself
you might have to get tased for that one
now having said all this there still is
a conversation to be had about police
brutality and excessive use of power and
violence despite what a lot of you may
think out there I'm sorry but police
brutality is real it's not a [ __ ]
myth it actually happens so for any of
you out there that want to say something
like there's no such thing as bad cops
only bad people [ __ ] you you useless
sack of pubic hair a badge doesn't erase
human fallacy and ill intent from a
piece of [ __ ] human being it just gives
that piece of [ __ ] a lot more power than
they should have now for some [ __ ]
reason every time somebody died from
excessive force or violence there's
always somebody out there to say that
they deserved it and it was their fault
right if he had not had asthma and a
heart condition it was so obese that
almost definitely he would not have died
from this you know people were saying
that he said 11 times or 7 times I can't
breathe the fact is if you can't read
you can't talk and there are going to be
certain cases where people are just
bullshitting but there are also going to
be cases where you just really can't say
[ __ ] for instance let's talk about the
62 year old elderly Korean woman that
was tackled and arrested by two cops
while she was going to church for
morning prayer security video shows a
mostly empty parking lot of a Koreatown
Church but what happens here in a few
moments has this 62 year old woman
Oakton June suing the LAPD two police
officers and the City of LA
lady comes up and honks horn at the cops
who's blocking the entrance to the
church so she can go to her morning
prayer oh and just in case she was too
crazy to handle the two cops reportedly
had four extra cruisers come over to
handle this crazy situation so they
decide to follow her acid then [ __ ] her
ass up because their lives were in
danger according to them they said they
had to do it reportedly due to mental
issues what what the [ __ ] kind of mental
issues are you talking about so let me
break this situation down for you she's
a Korean American right she doesn't
speak any English so because she needs
help she decides to dial nine-one-one
ironic right gets the operator on the
phone asking this person to help assess
the situation because she doesn't know
what's happening but it doesn't work so
because that doesn't work she decides to
call her husband to talk to the cops but
of course by that time the phone has
turned into a dangerous [ __ ] weapon
you know those Decepticons turning
phones into guns right you know what's
[ __ ] amazing about this [ __ ] just
because a person doesn't speak English
doesn't mean that they're [ __ ] insane
what the hell is wrong with some of you
people out there when you hear like an
accented English or a foreign language
you automatically assume that
something's wrong with them excuse me do
you know direction to cause school I'm
sorry speak English my English are
perfect okay once again just to put it
out there I don't hate cops listen I'm a
Korean American who has a Korean
American mother and if my mother did
some crazy-ass [ __ ] [ __ ] for the cops
like this day she by license the
registration hey first of all [ __ ] you
kids a black people name is supposed to
be a carpet don't you ever already to do
like a ketchup all the bread people you
know he's a minority
okay there Oh you you put me in a chair
that's the minority poor disapper cruz
and then she got her ass beat for it I
still wouldn't be okay with it but then
I would kind of ask my mom what the [ __ ]
were you thinking and you know what the
most upsetting part about all of this is
nobody is talking about this we talk
about police brutality a lot when it
comes to other ethnicities but when it
comes to a 62 year old elderly Korean
woman getting her [ __ ] ass handed to
her I have to scrape the [ __ ]
internet to find information about it
and interestingly enough what we're
finding is that if it doesn't really
happen to you it's not interesting
enough for you to go ahead and speak up
on it but by that point it's already too
late and then be honest with you I think
a lot of it has to do with a whole bunch
of us being apathetic to the issue like
it happened so often we don't really
give a [ __ ] about it anymore which
doesn't make sense because that's not
gonna help solve [ __ ] and you know what
I also get it it sucks as a cop that a
few bad seats out there make the rest of
you look bad but I'm sorry to say this
and you've probably heard this multiple
times but I'm just gonna say it again
that's a part of your [ __ ] job your
job carries that type of weight and
responsibility I think that a lot of us
here are tired of hearing their same
excuse it's not all cops it's not all
cops
we're tired of hearing that [ __ ] and
then I've heard other people say in
common [ __ ] like you don't know the
stress of what it's like to be a cop
you're right
I don't know I'm not a [ __ ] cop but
that's also not my job it's not my duty
to go ahead and protect citizens and
then abuse my power
so by that means me because you get
mistreated your job is really stressful
and you [ __ ] snap we should be okay
with it it doesn't work that way for any
[ __ ] job period if I [ __ ] worked
at Kinkos somebody called me a fat [ __ ]
and I slapped the [ __ ] [ __ ] out of
them do I still get to keep my job
I don't think so this is just my opinion
but when you took on that position of
power and Trust you don't get to choose
who you get to abuse when you're in a
bad mood to decide when you're gonna
snap depending on your situation
essentially what I'm saying is that we
are supposed to trust you with our lives
I think we have enough problems where
we're worried if something's gonna break
into our home whether we're gonna get
[ __ ] up on the street by a bunch of
thugs we don't want that same type of
fear from the people that's supposed to
protect us
you know what the sad thing about this
is is that this type of [ __ ] has been
happening for years and years it's just
that with technology and social media
it's a lot harder for the Bad Seeds to
get away with it and as a final note I
want you to know why I think this
situation is so [ __ ] serious the
Korean lady is suing you Asian people
don't sue anybody that's how serious it
is
that joke was in poor taste you [ __ ]
up